hello mama and papa slep i've been
married to my beautiful wife for seven
years
we are an interracial couple of hispanic
and asian
however we live in texas where
open-mindedness on interracial couples
is still not there
and people of all races are guilty of
this plenty of times people tend to
glance and stare sometimes in an
uncomfortable level
which does bother me to the point where
i want to begin making remarks of them
but i would like to avoid conflict
what kind of mental attitude should i
take to avoid this becoming a greater
problem in my head
or being able to just shove this to the
wayside and not care
do i answer that question i've almost
had this scenario i was dating this
italian woman from los gatos
years ago right and this was a small
town i could tell that they weren't all
about the internet she was a white chick
black chick black dude
and i could tell that they weren't all
uh
i could i felt like the community
wouldn't be as accepted
and i remember we were holding hands one
time going down the street and i told i
said you know what we don't
have to do this if it's gonna she was
like no
she said we got to show it she said
because if we're uncomfortable
we're going to make those people feel
uncomfortable you know what i'm saying
so my advice would would be to you got
you have to continue to live your life
and you show the affection that you want
and your and as long as nobody put their
hands on you or anything like that [ __ ]
them looks
and the power of how you feel in your
love it would it would
it will suppress all that dumb [ __ ] yeah
i've had a white girlfriend when we went
to for a walk i'd go
all right you leave now you're white in
20 minutes 20 minutes yes
you are damn no oh my god thank you
you're white korean
like i thought you were adopted son
you're like adopted asian
yes you are white koreans thank god
somebody
finally still validated did i not tell
you that on the phone his arm's frozen i
said you're white korean
i told you that i want to come here
early you say donna just go grab a cup
of coffee
that's very white that's very white
you're white korean son you are white
koreans
right i just want to say this you don't
date you don't even date in your race
she's filipinos she's asian no but
that's i'm talking about
[Laughter]
it's so funny that you say this my
friend you're white korean yeah
all right okay i have to say
this number one i want to answer another
question no we're not answering another
question
we're gonna we're gonna address this
real quick okay i wanted to end it but
we're not gonna end it right now all
right
i cannot help it that my korean parents
decided like okay we're gonna move to
green valley which is a suburb right
i cannot help it that we bought a house
in the middle of basically white town
everyone i get i understand why are you
white korean i
understand yeah it's you know but you
know number one
i will [ __ ] with koreans right i am
korean
when i go to korea or i'm at a korean
spa or like i feel korean
you know it's just that i have white
tendencies
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah you do i have white tendencies
when you know you know
if i'm on an airplane that's your
environment and i see the notebook on
will i watch i'll watch it
right yeah because i'll watch it i'll
watch it because my best friend do i cry
i cry
my best friend since childhood is korean
born and raised in l.a yeah but she is
so different from him
she is korean korean yeah and she makes
she's uncomfortable with how well
the reason why the reason why is because
her parents had to
keep pushing the culture on her kids
yeah she had to keep and i get it i get
it i have a friend um
esther cool i know esther well she's on
her podcast she's white korean
she's 100 white korean yeah yeah yeah
because you know uh
her family wanted her to understand i
get i'm not knocking for it but you
definitely do i listen to sarah
mclaughlin yes
yeah i mean your love is better than ice
cream
i love it i love that i love that song
okay my point is is this i have
tendencies but i will [ __ ] with gooks
yo you tell you white green yo i own
tiva's now
here we go so i'm black caucasian to a
certain extent well you're a woods guy
now
yeah worst man there is a little white
in you you know what
uh i uh
appreciate a lot of things about
white culture me too adventure the one
thing
you know i was really i appreciate it
like don't don't get me wrong say
everything about black culture but
i'm not afraid to dabble into it yeah me
either when i first started dating him i
couldn't believe
that he had never owned a rice cooker
much less knowing how to
cook rice at all i i couldn't [ __ ]
believe it
i love chicken pot pie listen man i
called it
i love chicken powder i i called it
she's excited
you're white korean and she said it
rewind it like
finally yeah someone gets but is there a
purple ring around my penis there is
that makes me very korean and here we go
now let's take it back to the beginning
of this show
these are the things that make me
uncomfortable and these are the things
that make me realize why i didn't want
to [ __ ] leave
i just came here to say make sure you
follow my podcast
everyone give him a round of applause
that was fantastic all right
god damn it shout out to eb
hey guys we got a couple of shout outs
for
peoples out there